in the thick forests of kosovo's
mountainous North there are few paths
even fewer people okay we go we go this
side police search teams here often
struggling to seek a route through what
started as a man
hunt you see bullet holes is now one
week later A desperate quest for
evidence weapons that we are finding all
over yesterday we found more than 10
Kalashnikov leftenant colonel elshani is
overseeing this effort a former Soldier
now focused on finding facts and
building a prosecution we are not an
army we are police force so basically we
deal with it as police force for days
his team has continued to uncover
discarded weapons and Military supplies
stretched out along several hillsides
the remnants of a raging gunfight that
ravaged a tiny Mountain community and
shocked an entire region these men
didn't care no
no no for the life of no one it's now
been more than a week since that
extraordinary unprecedented attack on a
village here in Northern kovo as you can
see there's still a very heavy police
presence here a lot of questions remain
unanswered what's clear though is there
was a huge array of Weaponry being
brought to bear with ferocity raining
down on police positions right here on
the entrance to the Village El chani
says despite the attacker's powerful
weapons they're training and tactics
seemed weak with none of his men
seriously injured in the subsequent
firefight that lasted hours kosovo's
government called The Assault part of a
larger plan to Annex territory in the
north where a predominantly ethnic Serb
population is now placed by heavily
armed ethnic Albanian officers not
always happily people in general don't
trust the police that was the problem
MRA Milich is executive director of a
nonprofit group that advocates for the
rights of ethnic serbs in Northern
Kosovo the first barrier is basically
inability to understand local community
inability to communicate in their native
language and vice versa and of course
that even deepen the mistrust could you
don't know what the other side is saying
and vice versa the cleanup from the
surprise attack is now almost complete
but this investigation could continue
for some time a heavy police presence
May remain here for months The Fallout
from this deadly incident could be felt
for far far longer Villa mark alaz bansa
Kosovo make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
alaz